So now that we're all set up
with our Play Games libraries,
we want to start adding some
achievements to our game.
And the first thing I'm
actually going to do
is add in our
built in controller
to view those achievements.
So I'm going to do that
by creating a button.
Let's put it on screen here.
This is good.
And we will say
view achievements.
And let's go over
into our sizing.
We're going anchor it
to the bottom right.
By the way, Xcode 5 auto layout
is much better than Xcode 4.
If I were to do
this from scratch,
I'd probably be doing that
here instead of these springs
and struts.
Anyway, we're just going
to call this achievements,
a little cleaner.
And now I'm going to go
into my helper editor here,
and I'll set up with an
outlet, control drag.
We'll call it view
achievements button.
One of these days I'm going
to misspell achievements.
It's going to be
really embarrassing.
And maybe up here, let's add
in our achievements button
was pressed action.
All right, with that set up,
let's go and edit this thing.
The first thing we're
going to do actually
is within refresh
interface based on sign in,
I'm going to say self dot
view achievements button
dot hidden equals not signed in.
So that we hide this
view achievements button
if you're not signed in.
Kind of makes sense.
The other thing
I want to do here
is something that has bugged me
since the last chapter, which
is in my finished
with auth error
handler, this refresh
interface based on sign in,
I want to move this outside
the if not error clause.
Because we'll want to refresh
the interface either way,
whether there's an error or not.
Trying silent sign in, will it
have finished at this point?
And maybe we'll want to
show the button again
if things have gone badly.
So anyway, it was bothering me.
I just wanted to get
around to fixing it.
So now let's get something to
happen when the user presses
this view achievements button.
We're going to create a
GPG achievement controller
equals GPG achievement
controller alloc init.
We need to set its
achievement delegate to self.
At least that's what
I'm going to do here.
And this achievement
delegate, by the way,
just has one method,
which is achievement view
controller did finish.
It's the method our
view controller here
is going to implement in
order to dismiss this view
controller when the
user is all done.
And then we display it like
we would any other modal view
controller.
So we're going to
call self present view
controller, our achievement
controller, animated yes.
And completion in this
case, will just be nil.
Now of course, we're
getting a warning,
because we set our
achievement delegate to self.
But our self is not yet a
GPG achievement delegate.
Luckily, we can fix
that right here.
And they get one other warning
that their required method,
achievement view
controller finish has not
been implemented.
I really feel like that there's
got to be some key combination
or something here that I can
click for Xcode to insert
a stub method for me.
I've not been able to find it.
If it exists, and
you know about it,
please leave it in the comments.
Because gee, it seems like
that would be awfully nice.
However, that said, it's
pretty easy for us to add,
since it does get
auto completed for us.
And basically we're just
going to dismiss view
controller animated,
yes with completion nil.
And that's all we need to.
These lines of code
have done all the work
we need to actually show
the achievements view
controller within our game.
So let's run this
and see what happens.
All right so I'm signed in.
I've got this
achievements button.
I'm going to click it.
And I get this lovely
achievements view controller,
which is empty.
And that's because
we haven't defined
any achievements for our game.
So I suppose this is correct.
I click the Done button.
It calls my delegate method,
which dismisses that view
controller, and there you go.
We can now view our
achievements within the game.
So maybe the next
step would actually
be to create some
achievements, and we
could do that developer console.
And so we'll tackle
that in the next lesson.